they probably didn't have any conception
of peripheral vision or or the fovea or
or i mean basically anything
they had some i mean because actually
was newton himself who probed a lot of
this for instance
uh newton the young newton
trying to work his way around what's
going on with colors
wanted to try and distinguish
colors that occur through natural
processes out there
and colors that are a result of our eyes
not operating right so you know what he
did it's a famous thing he took a stick
and he stuck that stick under his lower
eyelid and pushed up on his eyeball
and what that did
what produced colored circles
at diametrically opposite positions of
the stick in the eyeball and he moved it
around to see how they moved
trying to distinguish legit
right
i always have to tell my students don't
do this but
or do it if you want to be great
and remembered by uh human history
that's that there's a lot of equivalent
to sticking a stick into your eye in
modern day that
may pay off in the end
you